aerials getting start number 14 today
from john means four and three with a
272 era
trying to win that fifth game and it's
been the last win was the the no hitter
out soda one for one a single against
means and a fastball is outside ball
four
so the bases are loaded with nobody out
for the nationals that's are 35 and 14
when they score first if you're
wondering
high
bouncer low throw to second zimmerman
beats it out and the nats will take the
lead
with escobar crossing home plate
if it's only one nothing after base is
loaded nobody out you take it
and it might only be one nothing a slow
ground ball from harrison and label will
take it to second so base has loaded
nobody out after a walk
three straight nationals swing at the
first pitch and it's one nothing
and today it's paula espino first time
against the o's the last start july 20th
tossed five shutout innings allowing
just four hits and then that's six to
three win
trey mancini raking against the nets
three for eight in this series with a
home run
because he can do all those things
that ball is absolutely walloped oh how
far is this thing gonna go
trey mancini with a mammoth home run
my word
this is what espino can't do check this
out i mean he's trying to get it in i
mean it's belt high in the middle of the
plate at 89.
here's your result
now we always talk about camden yards
being a great place to hit it wouldn't
matter
oh that thing might be out in the polo
grounds that's 455 off the bat of trade
wow grand canyon had a chance
yosemite i mean you can just go to the
national parks
rxfinity powerful connection today this
is the connection that baseball can
provide trey mancini before the game
young man and a nick mark cake is jersey
and a big hug
for dad after the fact that's the
connection that
trey mancini can provide
off the field
right after we saw trey hit a home run
on it
and rivera hits another sky-high pop-up
and a few of those already today
fighting the sun mckenna will make the
catch
felika had no idea where it was it had
to be ryan mckenna in from left field
and
eventually it was
yeah heads up play and uh you know
that's kind of a
precursor of what needs to happen you
can never assume your infielder is going
to get it as he comes in and makes a
nice play routine if he kept running but
he stopped
and fellaini and right here
takes a look just in case he changed his
mind michael franco batting here in the
second franco just returning from the
injured list 3-2
breaking ball drilled left field
harrison back on a line out of here
2-1 orioles with the lead michael franco
sends this one out in a hurry to the
middle of the bleachers in left field
number 10 for franco the orioles second
home run it has many innings
smoked it
[Applause]
[Music]
i dropped it down like lamar he was a
catcher wasn't it yes he was uh you're
not the only baltimore celebrity in the
crowd today cal is here as well cows in
the front row
you get a chance to chat it up with cal
before the game i see what do you guys
talk about he was critiquing my throwing
motion just a little bit
he did ask me how far it seemed out
there
good ones
a ground ball guided to short valenca
turns one laba makes it two
really good pitch
one and two for ryan mckenna
hard-line drive out to left field his
first time seventh pitch coming to
mckenna and a 3-2 ball driven out to
center by ryan mckenna robles at the
wall he cannot get it
first home run in the big leagues for
ryan mckenna
just over the reach of robles
and the kid from grants pass oregon
is into the home run record books as a
major leaguer
i wanted to stay away you could see him
miss with some fastball stay out of the
middle of the play
roblox a very good defender but i think
they're helping him severino kind of the
celebration
turner rips one and it eats up the
shortstop felika
out into left center escobar will make
the turn and stay at second
and trey turner with a rocket gets the
nats in business oh in a park where the
ball flies ryan's just trying to get
something in the air here
that one flies deep right center
see
you later
just out of the reach of mullins and
ryan mr interleague zimmerman
has put the nats on top
fastball up
see you later
instant offense from ryan zimmerman
[Applause]
escobar oh for one today
oh he serves one to right that's a
beauty
stewart to his left escobar thus on to
second
and that'll get trey turner to the plate
and paul frye who came in on friday
night got four outs three strikeouts on
20 pitches 1-2 on turner
oh goodbye there it is delayed call but
the right call from edwin moscoso and
frye picks up a fourth straight
strikeout in this series
cedric mullins
with a line drive to lead it off and a
base hit in front of soto the orioles
have the tying run on in the first pitch
of the eight fitting against hudson
trey into right field base hit mancini
it is a pair of singles
from cedric and trey to start the
orioles down a run in the eight
broken back
and the natch will get the four six
three on a one hopper to escobar
and the battle won by daniel hudson's
and that's clinging to their lead and
hudson one more pitch to get it to the
ninth
fastball up he
struck him out
nice
all right brad hand is in the night you
know he's gonna try to slow things down
franco gets hit on an o2 and the orioles
have the lead off man on to the bottom
of the night
let's see
swing it away line drive into the gap
from ryan mckenna bronco turns second
he's gonna go all the way to third base
and he will make it
first and third nobody out of the ninth
ryan mckenna comes through
a 3-2
outside and the bases are jammed with
nobody out
and pat valencia
trying to
put the capper on maybe his best weekend
out of the year
veleka in the air to right field soto
back on it soto makes the catch broncos
scores to tie the game and the winning
run mckenna moves 90 feet closer
job well done by pat balaka and the o's
have tied it at four and another pinch
hitter it'll be ramon
urias who already has a walk-off hit
this season
and a ground ball to third fielded by
kibum to the plate save
mckenna scores
well there's your speed kevin
going on contact i'm sure they're going
to challenge this
and we are going to get a review here
so take a look i mean it's a nice play
you're kind of throwing it behind the
runner
so you have a lane you can't throw it
here's the angle there's the throw does
he get the hand in
boy hard to tell
umpire thinks he does this will be your
definitive play is the hand in
oh i'll tell you what bang bang they
called him safe
there's got to be something that
says otherwise i think that's got to
stand yeah you would think so we've
never been so excited for a joe west
call
he's safe
start the buses
the orioles have swept the nationals
right out of town